you know when donald trump became
president
it was already an unusual moment because
we had a billionaire
who was coming into office then when he
decided to
carry his whole business with him into
the white house
it was the first time that we had this
experiment and no one knew what was
going to happen you know what happens
when you take
a billion dollar business and you bring
it into the white house
so somebody said why did you appoint a
rich person
to be in charge of the economy
and what happens when you take the white
house and the presidency and politics
and impose it upon a billion dollar
business and
what we've seen in the last few years is
the results of that experiment
coming in on a day-to-day week-to-week
month-to-month basis
from the start of 2017
through all of 2018 to the end of 2019
if you add all of trump's revenue that
adds up to 1.9 billion dollars
three years 1.9 billion now revenue
means all of the money that's coming
into your business so everything that
people are paying this is not
necessarily
you know money that's landing in donald
trump's pocket because remember there's
a lot of expenses that he has to pay
so if you break down the 1.9 billion and
you say all right
let's look at trump's business now he
owns a lot of different assets okay
we're talking about
you know more than a dozen golf
properties he owns a bunch of commercial
real estate buildings in new york city
he owns hotels so you sort of have to
put them in segments
and the first segment that you can look
at is sort of the golf
courses and clubs so this is mar-a-lago
doral he's got three properties over in
europe and a bunch of golf courses in
the united states
if you add all of that revenue up over
three years that's about 753 million
dollars so a ton of money
coming in through the golf businesses in
the club business
the next biggest segment is the
commercial real estate so this is
you know the retail space in trump tower
the office space in 1290 avenue in the
americas the
office space in 555 california street
most of his commercial real estate
is still in new york city but there are
some exceptions the biggest one of
course
is he owns a 30 stake in 555 california
industry
in san francisco you never hear about
this asset but believe it or not it's
the most valuable asset in his entire
portfolio just doesn't have his name on
it
and so people don't talk about it a lot
then the next thing
is if you look at sort of the licensing
the management
and the hotel's businesses so these are
different businesses this could be
trump lending his name to somebody who
wants to build a tower in turkey
it could be trump lending his name to
somebody who wants to sell mattresses
it could also be trump running a hotel
in washington dc
or running a hotel condo complex in las
vegas
if you sort of mesh all that together
the licensing and the hotel businesses
and
the reason that you mesh them together
is because a lot of the licensing
is in hotels so you put that whole
segment together
that's about 411 million dollars
the next thing are the asset sales so
yes donald trump became president
he handed over management day-to-day
responsibilities to his kids
but he still owns the properties that he
owned before
and many of those properties he's been
selling off as he's been president these
are small deals they don't
get a lot of attention but if you add up
all those transactions
and there are more than 100 of them from
through 2019 that's another 118 million
dollars
that donald trump is taking it then the
final one is
what we term other um i think that trump
the game is going to be a hit because
it's trump
and everything he does seems to turn
into gold this is kind of a grab bag so
donald trump does a lot of crazy stuff
in business so he sells books he
runs a skating rink in central park he
runs restaurants
in trump tower at his golf club in doral
he has a carousel in central park he
does all these
sort of random things if you lump all
that stuff into one last category that's
about 91 million dollars
so then you take your math question you
say all right so we've got 1.9 billion
dollars we've split it up into all these
different segments
now let's dive into each one of those
segments and figure out how much of that
money actually
turns into profit you know trump's
hotels and his golf businesses
get a ton of headlines because they're
visible you can walk into them
they're you know interesting they're
dynamic all of that
but if you look at his profits
we're measuring this by earnings before
interest taxes depreciation and
amortization
so if you look at that and you add it up
over three years we're estimating it's
about 470 million dollars for the whole
for the whole portfolio now here's where
uh it gets interesting so 313 million
dollars of that
is from the commercial real estate
business that's because it's a really
really profitable business you don't
have that many expenses
when you just own a building and you're
renting it out you've got to hire
a guy you know downstairs to check
people's ids you have to hire some
maintenance people to clean up
but that's you know about it there's not
all that much stuff that you have to do
if on the other hand you look at the
golf business which takes in the most
revenues 570 million dollars
it only turns 85 million dollars is our
estimate
of those in operating profits that's a
business that takes a ton of work
same thing with the hotel low margin
business you've got to pay you've got to
clean somebody's sheets every night
you know you've got to have a restaurant
there you've got to make sure that
everything looks perfect
at all times and it's not you know
people don't necessarily treat hotels
like they treat their offices so your
your cleaning expenses are doing more
and that means that your profit margins
are going to be less
so if you look at the profitability of
the whole enterprise
we've got 313 million for the commercial
real estate
85 million dollars for the golf courses
and clubs
60 million dollars for the hotels
licensing and management
and then about 12 million million
dollars for everything else
there's a lot still to learn and a lot
to look at
i just finished up my book and so that
means that i
which is called white house inc and it's
all about trump's business you know you
start a book and you think oh
i'm gonna you know figure out the full
story of trump's business you can't
figure out the full story the story
never ends it keeps going it's an
operating business
and there's always more and more to look
at